[Music]
well guys apparently they have found the
holy grail
what for real young forever oh
i thought it's the actual cup the actual
cup yeah the cup of christ
no one wants to stay young forever we're
like nah
i wanna just wanna see like an old
wooden cup well i'm not talking about
the cup
i'm talking about staying young forever
what is it exercise water and sleep
no so i wanna i want the
what do you call it the virality or like
the the
very right literary virility of the
youth
he wants to be able to [ __ ] forever oh i
got it keep your dick up forever
like and be able to show like the yeah
like like potent yeah potent and like
like healthy and stuff like that but
then i don't really care about
aging the aging part oh like i could be
a [ __ ] hard-ass grandpa
yeah but i worry about the aches that
they want the aging
part that i'm like [ __ ] that oh my can't
cuz of my back and all that stuff but
what if you have virality if you have
vitality
you don't there's grapples that [ __ ]
really virality is part of like so like
keeping your dick up is part of not
having
like minority and vitality i think i
think virality is
but that's just healthy as [ __ ] all
right has to do with
being able to have kids easy and vitaly
tv too yeah
i want to be able to do pranks forever
dude i accidentally introduced him as
that at the [ __ ] con
because i didn't know him and so i was
just i was supposed to introduce
everybody and i said vittel
vitality's tv and he was [ __ ] pissed
at me like i was trolling him but i
really didn't know wow you just pissed
that you were trolling him
he thought that i was trolling him but
that's what he you don't know my name
bro come on bro
i have all this [ __ ] bro and i was like
i don't know if i can know i don't know
how to say it i'm sorry
just to clarify the difference because
that google i was like wait you just
said by our
virality and vitality there's two but
virality means
the state of or condition of being viral
the tendency to spread
by word of mouth that's not applicable
here
vitality is the capacity to live and
develop
energy or vigor that which distinguish
living from
non-living things life animatedness yeah
i think i said vitality first
she did it no she said no he said
virality i said by town steve said
virality but to correct he wants to be
veril
no look that up like a a very casual
very difficult
is like you know you want to be able to
be potent when you [ __ ] i spell that
v-e-r-i-l-e what part of what he was
talking about i think strength
is a sex drive well that's confusing is
there virality
okay i i go back there is i go back to
what my original
that's i didn't know i thought i didn't
know that uh vitality was about
sexual incoming until he said it's all
no vitality is like
life that's what i meant and then he
added the coming part so i was like fine
i'll tell you no listen
virility v-i-r-i-l-i-t-y
the quality of having strength energy
and a strong sex drives manliness
i like that too virility she's trying to
help this is how you say it
so there's virality and then there's
vitality
which are more similar than virality
and then there's reptility which is how
scaly your skin is dude if i didn't
learn this
language being born i know [ __ ] this
language
[ __ ] this we still don't even know the
language let's listen to us
yeah how come people that english is
their second language no more than we
they're smarter than we are they care
more than we do about it oh
damn but i know what joe's talking about
though he just wants to be an old guy
that's strong and young and defies his
age what's the [ __ ] yes
i don't think that's what he wants okay
what does joe want he wants to spread
viruses
virality chorality
anyway so tell us about sin of youth
okay the fountain of youth they're
saying that may be made out of air and
not water
here's the thing so researchers from tel
aviv university they used a hyperbaric
oxygen chamber to target specific
cells and dna that is linked to shorter
lifespans
and so what they did is they placed
elderly plate that they placed elderly
patients
or participants in the chamber for 90
minutes a day
five days a week for three months and
studies its
impact on these cells called senescent
cells which are associated with tissue
and organ deterioration
they also measured the length of each
person's telomere
which is a molecule linked to premature
cellular aging okay what they found out
is that
in those three months the average length
of 20
uh of the telomeres had enlarged
sorry they enlarged by 20 percent um and
while their sensing cells
decreased by up to 30 37
by the end of the trial which is the
equivalent of growing
25 years younger what the [ __ ] is that
just by going to this tent uh a chamber
tank
what's in the chamber intent again i
missed that no there's no tension
i mean these chambers are usually tense
oh well i don't know they i don't know
but they call it it's a hyperbaric
oxygen chamber
i like the name sounds like hella high
tech like you're about to go into this
alien ship
and then like into this coffin kind of
thing but then like in reality it's a
tent with a [ __ ] oxygen mask or
something and if it's is it hypo
hyper hyper so they it's here we go
again
it's over oxygenated a lot of oxygen
yeah it's extra oxygen yeah got it so
what they did
is um yeah teacher so like if i get
oxygen tank and put it on my face i
become young as [ __ ] that's what it's
saying
in a tent only you have to be when i sit
in a tent yeah and it only is younger in
your face too that's what she said
it's younger in your dna oh down to the
dna
yeah so it's like targeting so you
become stupid as [ __ ] what
you think about it think about how dumb
you were 20 years ago
no so they're saying that the
pressurized chamber uh
it triggered brief oxygen shortages
which caused
cell regeneration shortages the lack of
oxygen that makes your body go oh [ __ ]
and then uh something like that is that
why william hoff is so buff
yes so i've i've read into like you know
like the the contrast training where
people go in like super hot water and
then cold water
and stuff like that so when your body
goes through controlled conflict that's
what keeps your
keeps your keeps you young because your
body goes oh [ __ ] you actually have
challenges and i have to overcome these
challenges
so i have to keep maintaining myself
when you're when it's too comfortable
too complacent
your body's like i don't really need any
of this stuff usually i start withering
away start aging
so it's actually like difficulties keep
you young yeah but i thought
difficulties keep you stressed
i think that's your mental part of it
yes so if you view these difficulties
like oh why the [ __ ]
like why is the world so hard on me then
you're happy
like how your immune system gets
stronger when you get a little sick all
the time
you're exposed to different but then if
you're like super sick and you're
in the hospital bed and then you're just
deteriorating away because your body is
not strong enough
so you want to go through physical
difficulties and challenges controlled
but you want to have a positive mindset
and that's like the ultimate oh that's
fun that's like mountain biking or like
yeah yeah it's cold outside let's jump
in the poo
and then you go like that yeah because
you're stressed out physically but then
you're having a good time yeah
they even do that like for your skin for
example like micro needling
it's like it's puncturing your actual
skin cells which is like causing it to
bleed or whatever
like it's actually damaging the cells
but because it's like such a
micro controlled damaging it ends up
having your skin
heal itself which is like keeping it
like smoother younger and like it
actually is good for getting rid of like
acne scars and stuff
but so why do you need to be in a tent
yeah
i'm like he brought up the tent i'm
googling it it's obviously a key
component
oh you know oh cause this is intense oh
it's so intense i don't know you're
already a dad
[Laughter]
you know what people keep saying that
they're like look it's not tent oh no
it's there
oh yeah dude it's like a [ __ ]
cryogenic chamber like a coffin looking
thing
so what do they do just choke them uh
chocolate powder no
it's just reduce oxygen uh
i don't know they're just talking about
the fact that they're using oxygen in a
very controlled way
somehow that it's targeting like tissues
in the dna like cells
in your dna and it's making you younger
so i'm 25 years younger off of this
yes in three months wow 90 minutes a day
five days a week for three months that's
like a reasonable
like schedule 90 minutes a day yeah
for five days not even seven days can
you be still
in a chamber for 90 minutes just put on
a movie you have to be still
we're not talking about you joe we know
you can't talk about being still it's
just being in this chamber
bro just binge watching three episodes
of like chopped so the reason why
you dropped your phone on your face the
reason why i say a tent because a lot of
fighters do this
so you can sleep you could be in there
for like eight hours does it count when
you sleep
just bring an axe or something and you
can be in there like oh
see that okay now that'll keep me busy
for 90 minutes
you know what's also really interesting
is that these participants they didn't
change
anything about their lifestyle they
didn't they didn't go on a diet they
didn't change their medications
this is the [ __ ] fountain of youth
for the lazy [ __ ] is there
is there picks of these people no of
course there's nothing i want to say
they don't give you photos in a study
what i don't understand is what's the
difference between going to that chamber
thing and breathing out of the thing
image of you that gives you oxygen and
then but
versus like just breathing oxygen out
because this isn't a control
environment so you gotta do this dude
let's control the body
i don't know i'm not the scientist you
gotta do this time
okay for 90 minutes a day the wim hof
breathing technique
you hold your breath for like a minute
yeah can't you can't you do the
controlled stuff outside okay
that's like the biohack version of that
it's hard to do it though like this is
probably easier
because you got to [ __ ] breathe hard
as [ __ ] for like
30 times and then hold your breath and
then try to hold it for a minute and a
half that's just harder
that's more an eastern medicine idea got
it yeah
being in a [ __ ] machine like this is
so much easier i like my western meds
so here's a quote for from a doctor who
co-authored
the study he said what is remarkable to
note in our study
is that in just three months of therapy
we were able to achieve such significant
telomere elongation at rates far beyond
any of the of the current available in
interventions or lifestyle modifications
but that's month this this thing grows
all these mushrooms in no time yeah
mk dot farm slash joe are you next gonna
be able to sell like some like magic
mushroom stuff
no everyone keeps asking me that but
like i'm just like we don't wanna go to
[Music]
jail
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you